we are taking a listen now
into hear from chuck schumer mitch
mcconnell just
finished speaking and chuck schumer just
began to speak a few minutes ago let's
listen in
were places of shelter until the
evacuation is was ordered
leaving rioters to stalk these hallowed
halls
lawmakers and our staffs average
citizens who love their country serve it
every day
feared for their lives i understand that
one woman was shot
and tragically lost her life we mourn
her
and feel for her friends and family
these images were projected to the world
foreign embassies cabled home their
capital their home capitals to report
the harrowing scenes at the very heart
of our democracy
this will be a stain on our country not
so easily washed away
the final terrible indeli
indelible legacy of the 45th president
of the united states undoubtedly our
worst
i want to be very clear those who
perform these reprehensible acts cannot
be called protesters
no these were rioters and
insurrectionists
goons and thugs domestic
terrorists they do not represent america
there were a few thousand violent
extremists who tried to take over the
capitol building and attack our
democracy
they must and should be prosecuted to
the full extent of the law
hopefully by this administration if not
certainly by the next they should be
they should be provided
no leniency i want to thank the many of
the capitol hill police and secret
service and local police who kept us
safe today
and worked to clear the capital and
return it to its rightful owners and its
rightful purpose
i want to thank the leaders democrat and
republican
house and senate it was speaker pelosi
leader mcconnell
leader mccarthy and myself who came
together and decided
that these thugs would not succeed that
we would finish the work of our
constitute that our constitution
requires us to complete
in the very legislative chambers of the
house and senate
that were desecrated but we know always
belong to the people and do again
tonight but make no mistake
make no mistake my friends today's
events did not happen
spontaneously the president who promoted
conspiracy theories that motivated these
thugs
the president who exhorted them to come
to our nation's capital
egg them on
he hardly ever discourages violence and
more often encourages it
this president bears a great deal
of the blame this mob
was in good part president trump's doing
senator chuck schumer there reflecting
on today's historic events we will
continue to monitor this for you we're
streaming it live on our website at
8newsnow.com
and of course cbs evening news coming up
here in a few minutes we'll have more